Jack was swimming deep underwater, wondering
why he had such a pounding headache when he
suddenly had a terrifying realization.
He had no idea where he was or what he was
doing.
There was a nagging feeling that he must have
a specific reason to be here — you don’t
just end up deep in the ocean with a diving
suit on by chance.
Yet he had no idea what he was supposed to
be doing.
He wasn’t sure he cared, either.
He was more worried about the throbbing pain
in his head and the vision of two eyes staring
at him out of the dark that he couldn’t
get out of his mind.
His heart began to race, as he wondered what
to do and how to get help.
He was in the middle of the ocean and appeared
to be all alone.
He couldn’t see anything in the dark water
except for this weird, gray substance in front
of him.
Maybe he was going to die here, alone.
Without knowing if anyone could even hear
him, he began to speak aloud about how he
was consumed by sickness and that darkness
was all around him.
This is the story of one of the most powerful
and dangerous anomalies yet discovered...
SCP-3000.
Before Jack’s descent into despair, the
SCP Foundation had mandated an exploratory
expedition off the coast of Bangladesh.
After receiving a few strange reports from
locals and fishermen, the foundation suspected
an SCP was lurking in the water and positioned
a few personnel to investigate.
The crew expected danger — or maybe even
death — but what they got instead was far
stranger and more ominous.
All of the men had been verified to be in
sound mental states when the mission set out,
but a few of them reported feeling strange
and uneasy as the submarine descended into
the ocean.
Before long, a veteran agent named Dr. Williams
began to panic in a way that was completely
out of character.
He started sweating profusely, shaking, and
wouldn’t listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer.
It might seem like a relatively normal reaction
for anyone descending into the depths of the
ocean to meet with a monster they don’t
know anything about, but Dr Williams was a
seasoned professional who had been on hundreds
of such missions before.
There was no logical reason for him to act
like this.
Although the reaction of Dr. Williams was
the most extreme, he wasn’t the only one
who started to feel strange.
Multiple agents developed a creeping feeling
of unease that swept over them.
One of the calmer men tried to reason with
Dr Williams, asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was feeling.
That’s when things got even stranger.
Not only was the doctor extremely anxious,
but he now seemed incapable of giving a real
response to any questions thrown at him.
He could only mutter that he was missing something
but he wasn’t sure what.
Knowing that many SCPs can bend reality and
the human mind, many of the personnel began
to have second thoughts about the mission
and even asked for permission to call off
the mission.
But they were mandated to continue — so
on they went.
As the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean, things only got worse.
Even the previously calm crew members became
spooked and antsy, while the ones who were
already anxious were now sweating and jittering.
As for Dr Williams, he was now pacing back
and forth around the submarine, saying things
nobody could understand.
Every time he looked at his colleagues and
close friends, he seemed to stare straight
through them and would call them by the wrong
names.
It was as if his mind had moved to a different
dimension.
Whenever someone asked him to perform his
normal duties, he looked more confused than
ever.
Still, the team went deeper.
Dr Williams began to whimper and say the word
“no” repeatedly, growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others were
forced to sedate him.
Just then, something came into view.
It was what would come to be known as SCP-3000.
The thing was huge — so huge that its whole
body couldn’t be seen out of the submarine
window.
It was a horrible, eel-looking creature with
a head as big as a town and haunting eyes
that lit up the black ocean around it.
But perhaps the strangest part was that this
giant eel seemed to be producing a weird,
gray liquid.
Even the sedative wasn’t enough to keep
Dr Williams calm anymore.
There was a strange, blank look in his eyes,
as if the light and life had left them.
He just began screaming “no” repeatedly
again and wouldn’t respond to any attempts
to calm him down.
Not that anyone else was very capable of calming
him down at this point.
Even the crew members that had been holding
up well were starting to act strangely, and
nobody could get the image of those ominous
eyes out of their heads.
Then, things went from bad to worse.
Williams began screaming and shouting madly
as if he was being tortured by an unseen force.
The men tried to restrain him, but it was
no use.
He began smashing his head against the submarine
window until it cracked, putting the whole
mission and everyone’s life at risk.
He fell to the ground, injured, chanting that
there was nothing.
Whatever that meant.
It was an emergency scenario.
They began applying first aid to Williams
and the submarine ascended to the surface
as quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window to
explode.
By the time they reached the surface, Williams
was dead.
But there was something even more chilling
than the circumstances of his death.
Every single man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days that
came afterward: the image of the eel-like
creature's eyes seemed burned in their minds
permanently.
It would haunt their waking hours for the
rest of their lives and sleep was no escape
either, as they would appear in both their
dreams and nightmares alike forever.
A second mission had to be sent to gather
more information about this strange beast.
Already, there were many theories and question
marks surrounding SCP-3000.
How big was it really?
Was it sentient?
What was the liquid for?
None of the men who had been on the previous
mission were willing to return to the waters,
but a new group of brave recruits volunteered.
They were about to find out what so many in
history have learned the hard way - that bravery
and foolishness are often mistaken for the
same thing.
This time the mission would not be in a submarine,
but in dive suits, in order to observe the
anomaly in even closer detail, and to eliminate
the chance of one team member self-sabotaging
the submarine, killing them all.
They were transported to the location by boat
and the three men splashed into the ocean.
They descended, and at first, everything was
going well.
In case anything went wrong, the three of
them were tethered together for extra security.
But the deeper into the ocean they swam and
the closer they got to SCP-3000’s location
they got, the stranger things became.
Just like on the last mission.
First, there were a few minor cases of confusion.
One of the team, Jack, thought it was his
responsibility to lead the navigation — but
another, Roberto, also thought this was his
job.
In fact, navigation was actually the job of
a third team member, Amir, but he seemed to
have forgotten.
Everyone was getting confused.
The team listening in on the conversations
at Foundation headquarters grew increasingly
concerned about what they could hear.
Was everyone losing their minds?
Hopefully nobody was about to pull another
Dr Williams on them.
Still, the project leads couldn’t afford
to tell the men to come back to the surface.
The foundation badly needed any information
they could get on this SCP, whatever the cost,
so they told the men to press on.
Things only got worse.
Roberto was asking to speak to a colleague
who passed away two years ago, while the others
began to mutter indistinguishable phrases
about eyes and darkness.
Not too dissimilar to the ramblings of Dr
Williams.
It increasingly beginning to look like a suicide
mission.
Then, there was silence.
What was going on?
Each of the men had completely lost it, to
the point that they cut the tether that was
holding them together.
All alone, Jack couldn’t remember where
he was or why he was here.
He desperately looked around to try and gauge
his surroundings, but he could only see darkness.
All he could think about was a pair of large
eyes and an overwhelming fear of despair and
anxiety.
And this weird gray fluid that was now floating
in front of him.
The Foundation listened as Jack started reciting
a creepy speech about being on the edge of
nothing, inches from oblivion, with a sickness
in his mind and nothing but a pair of eyes
in front of him.
They listened in horror as they heard movement
through the radio.
It sounded like a huge creature was swimming
toward the men.
It had to be SCP-3000.
But all three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even see
what was in front of them, claiming they couldn’t
see anything in the darkness
There was silence for half a minute, with
the team listening in fearing the worst.
Then, they heard some more unintelligible
mutterings.
The men must be alive, but what on earth was
going on?
The gibberish started again.
Two of the men were screaming that Jack had
just been swallowed whole and that they were
being sucked in too.
Why couldn’t they just swim away?
It was chaos but then, a few moments later,
Roberto spoke into the radio, saying he was
floating alone in the middle of the ocean
and had now moved away from the eyes of SCP-3000.
He finally seemed capable of forming coherent
thoughts and speech.
After what had just happened, Roberto now
had a theory.
He thought that, somehow, it was impossible
to think straight around SCP-3000.
When he’d been close enough to see the eyes,
Roberto had felt a throbbing pain in his brain
and been unable to think about anything.
Perhaps it was something to do with that mysterious
gray liquid.
Even more slime was now coming out of SCP-3000
now, and Roberto was determined to get a sample,
despite the warnings from HQ.
In one final burst of motivation, he swam
close enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample collection
unit that was designed to float to the surface
for collection later.
He had acquired some very important data,
but he seemed to have lost all hope of preserving
his life.
Roberto started telling the team over the
radio that he was dying that his heart rate
was too high, but cautioned that it would
be too dangerous for anyone to try and rescue
him.
The personnel continued to try and communicate
with Roberto to figure out what was going
on, but his words had stopped making any sense
until finally he went quiet.
Minutes turned into hours, hours turned into
days, and still, there was no sign of Roberto
or the rest of the divers.
After three days, his radio, which had only
been sending a steady stream of static, finally
stopped working altogether and he was presumed
dead.
However, the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of the
foundation researchers.
It turned out to be a viscous substance now
known as Y909, a chemical compound and extremely
strong anesthesia.
Y909 causes head pain, paranoia, fear, panic,
memory loss, and confusion — explaining
what happened to Dr Williams and the diving
trio.
The collection of Y909 may have resulted in
two disastrous missions, but there’s a silver
lining as the substance ended up becoming
an invaluable tool for the SCP foundation.
Its ability to make people forget what just
happened to them can be used to eliminate
knowledge of threatening SCPs among the public.
It also helps the foundation staff cope with
the traumatic experiences they encounter on
their missions.
Although other amnestics can be used for the
same purpose, none are as powerful as the
one produced by SCP-3000.
Before its discovery, the amnestics used would
break down too quickly, not fare well in storage,
or cause undesirable side effects.
The only problem is the method of sourcing.
The only way to obtain Y909 is somewhat ethically
questionable for most people.
SCP-3000 produces Y909 after eating, so the
best way to stock up on it is by feeding the
creature.
Sedated D-class personnel from the foundation
are sent on missions supposedly to observe
the anomaly up close, unaware that this mission
is one way only.
Other divers are then sent later to collect
the fluid from a safe distance and store it.
Of course, it’s all for the greater good
of humanity.
Now, the foundation protects SCP-3000 as best
as it can guard something hundreds of kilometers
long.
The area is carefully patrolled and members
of the public are not allowed to enter the
part of the bay where it resides.
Anybody who accidentally comes into contact
is contained.
Eventually another pair of Foundation doctors
went down in a submarine to try and learn
more about SCP-3000.
One became so affected by Y909 that he began
hallucinating.
He started talking about Anantashesa, the
king of serpents in Hinduism.
Anantashesa is believed to be all that will
be left after the end of the world because
it exists throughout all of time simultaneously.
The doctor said he believed that this was
in fact Anantashesa, that SCP-3000 simply
shows us that eventually everyone dies and
fades into the darkness of oblivion,right
before he exited the submarine and swam right
into its mouth.
Luckily for now, SCP-3000 seems to be in a
sort of hibernation state.
It rarely moves and it doesn’t hunt — although
it will eat when fed.
But no one knows when or if it will wake,
or what it is capable of if it does.
Will it destroy the world?
Or simply drive us all insane.